hello my name is Gordon cover I work for
gems education a private schools divider
based in Dubai I have been asked to
answer the question that how can the
youths today in the region make a
difference I would point to two things
very simple number one is continue to
pursue their education having that
education and proceeding through all the
stages from secondary to the university
level and beyond will be a massive help
in increasing competitiveness of the
region and unlocking their own potential
number two I would suggest could be
civic engagement getting youth involved
in local community practice political
engagement setting the agenda talking to
private private sector public sector
leaders and really making their voice
heard if if these today can do both this
thing get educated fulfil their
potential realise that the competitive
nature of the marketplace and how much
they they have to bring I think a lot
could happen in a very short space of
time